we have a voicemail number it's 2192
david p
here's a very fair question about the
death rate in different states from
coronavirus take a listen
hi david um short term member here
um i was wondering if you could walk uh
me and possibly the show
through uh why new york state has
a relatively high death rate um for
covid
and if states like florida then i think
california have significantly lower
death rates are those states lying uh is
there something else going on
et cetera um thanks appreciate it so
this is a pretty big topic
and certainly it's possible that some
states are just lying so we don't know
the real deaths per capita but let's
assume
the data are accurate which are that in
new york
the death rate has been about 1700 per
million from the virus whereas in
florida it's been only 500 per million
there's a couple things to consider and
the the real answer is probably a
combination of all of these
first of all the places that were hit
earlier by virtue of having
more direct flights to the source areas
of infection which are china
and certain countries in europe like new
york uh got hit
and overwhelmed before we understood we
were going to have to do massive social
distancing so the hospitals whenever
hospitals get overwhelmed or close to it
the care suffers and you would expect a
higher death rate
number two uh we also uh
now are doing a better job of
keeping the hospitals less full and so
that is helping to keep the death rate
down in some of the later infection hot
spots
but number three it's also a question of
timing if this goes
on for a long time you would expect
because remember deaths per capita never
go down
because the population at least over you
know the population is relatively fixed
and so over time the death rate per
capita is just going to keep going up in
place
in in every state but it's going to go
up faster in certain places than others
so
it's a perfectly reasonable question
when you get hit earlier
you're less prepared to deal with the
virus also now that there are some
treatments with some level of
effectiveness dexamethasone as one
and there are others that are considered
to be somewhat effective to different
degrees
you would expect that that would also
keep deaths down relative
to the number of cases so relatively
well studied a fair question
and a good one to understand also
important in thinking about how we deal
with what is expected to be a spike in
the fall as well
because states that are less
well-resourced when it comes to
medical resources are going to more
quickly get overwhelmed if we don't
control the spread as the flu season
coincides
with possibly a spike in coronavirus
something important to keep in mind
on the bonus show today we will talk
about the nba playoff boycotts
related to what's going on in wisconsin
we will talk about jeff bezos becoming
the first person ever worth 200 billion
dollars what does it say about our
economy
and our culture and we will also talk
about donald trump's
insane naturalization stunt during the
first night of the republican national
convention one woman who was in the
video
had no idea that she was going to be
part of the republican national
convention she's not particularly
pleased i don't think you will be
shocked
to hear that people did not know they
were going to be propaganda pieces
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show become a member at
joinedpakman.com to access it
instantly